Esto es lo básico de mi trabajo.
Me especializo en que llegue a todo el público.
¿Qué significa eso? Otro argot.
En realidad significa diseñar campañas informativas
para que los candidatos y votantes
que no han tenido la oportunidad de participar o votar,
entiendan dónde, cuándo, y cómo registrarse;
dónde, cuándo y cómo votar;
¿Por qué es importante participar?
Podría por ejemplo idear una campaña especifica para captar a las mujeres
y asegurar que puedan participar,
que puedan formar parte del proceso.
A las personas jóvenes también.
Toda clase de persona.
Personas discapacitadas.
Tratamos de informar a todos.
Y no siempre es fácil porque, regularmente en este trabajo,
me he dado cuenta a través del tiempo que llevo haciendo esto,
que las palabras se quedan cortas,
y entonces ¿Qué hacer?
Afganistán.
Es un país con altos niveles de analfabetismo,
y queríamos hacer algo en el año 2005,
organizamos dos elecciones en el mismo día,
y la razón fue porque la organización era increíblemente difícil,
parecía ser más eficiente hacerlo de esa forma.
Lo fue,
pero por otra parte, explicar dos elecciones en vez de una,
fue mucho más complicado.
Para ello recurrimos a muchas imágenes,
y cuándo llegó la hora de la votación,
tuvimos problemas porque mucha gente quería participar,
teníamos 300 candidatos para 52 puestos,
en la Wolesi Jirga, que son las elecciones parlamentarias.
Y para el Consejo Provincial, teníamos aún más candidatos.
Teníamos 330 para 54 puestos.
Ahora hablando del diseño de la boleta,
así se veía la boleta electoral.
Es del tamaño de un periódico.
Está fue la boleta del Wolesi Jirga.
(Risas)
Si, y esta --
esta fue la boleta del Consejo Provincial.
Aún más grande.
Como pueden ver, usamos muchos símbolos y cosas parecidas.
Y tuvimos otros problemas en el Sur de Sudán.
El Sur de Sudán fue un caso muy diferente.
Teníamos mucha gente que nunca había votado,
y niveles extremos, muy extremos de analfabetismo,
Una infraestructura muy pobre.
Por ejemplo -- Se trata de un país del tamaño de Texas más o menos.
Habían siete kilómetros de caminos pavimentados,
siete kilómetros en todo el país,
y eso incluye la pista donde aterrizamos los aviones
en el Aeropuerto Juba.
Así que transportar materiales electorales, etc.,
es muy difícil.
Las personas no tenían idea de como lucía una caja.
Era muy complicado,
por lo que usar comunicación verbal era la manera de proceder,
pero habían 132 idiomas.
Por lo que era un enorme desafío.
Después llegué a Túnez en 2011.
Era la Primavera Árabe.
Se generó mucha esperanza por ese enorme movimiento
que acontecía en la región.
En Libia, Egipto, Yemen.
Era un acontecimiento histórico enorme.
Estaba sentada con la comisión electoral,
y hablábamos sobre varios aspectos de la elección,
los escuchaba usar palabras que nunca había oído,
había trabajado con iraquíes, con jordanos, egipcios,
y de repente, usaban esas palabras,
yo sólo pensaba "Esto es raro."
Y lo que realmente lo ocasionó fue la palabra "observador".
Discutíamos sobre los observadores electorales,
y el comisionado de la elección hablaba sobre "mulahiz" en árabe.
Significa "notar" en un sentido pasivo,
como en, "Noté que llevaba puesta una franela azul clara."
¿Fui y verifique si la franela era azul clara o no?
Ese es el rol de un observador electoral.
Es muy activo, se rige por muchos tratados,
y tiene una función de control.
Luego me llamó la atención que en Egipto,
estaban usando el término "mutabi," que significa "seguir."
Por lo que ahora teníamos seguidores de una elección.
Y eso no es lo correcto,
porqué existe un término que fue aceptado y es utilizado,
que es la palabra "muraqib" que significa "un controlador."
Tiene la función de controlar.
Pensé: tres palabras para un concepto. Eso no está bien.
Y con nuestros colegas pensamos que quizás era nuestro rol
asegurarnos que se entiendan las palabras
y crear un marco de referencia
que pueda ser usado en toda la región árabe.
Y eso es lo que hicimos.
Junto a mis colegas,
creamos el "Léxico Árabe de Terminología Electoral,"
y trabajamos en ocho países diferentes.
Significó definir 481 términos,
que formaron la base de todo lo que se necesita saber
si vas a organizar una elección democrática.
Definimos estos términos,
trabajamos con los colegas Árabes,
y llegamos a un acuerdo sobre cuál sería la palabra adecuada
a utilizar en Árabe.
Porque el lenguaje Árabe es muy diverso, y eso es parte del problema.
Pero hay 22 países que hablan Árabe,
y hablan el Árabe estándar moderno,
que se usa en toda la región
en periódicos y transmisiones,
Pero por supuesto, de un país a otro el lenguaje cotidiano varía
-- dialectos, coloquialismos, etc.
Este era un grado más de dificultad.
Por una parte tienes el problema
que el lenguaje no es totalmente maduro,
nuevos neologismos surgían, nuevas expresiones.
Definimos todos estos términos,
utilizando los ocho corresponsales que teníamos en la región.
Les enviamos el borrador,
y nos respondieron.
"Si, entendemos el concepto,
y estamos de acuerdo con él,
pero así lo decimos en nuestro país."
No vamos a armonizar o forzar la armonización
Estamos tratando de facilitar entendimiento entre las personas.
En amarillo, se obvservan las diferentes expresiones en uso
en los diferentes países.
Felizmente puedo decir que después de tres años lo produjimos
porque también terminamos el borrador y lo llevamos a su ejecución,
nos sentamos con las comisiones electorales de los países,
debatimos, definimos y refinamos el borrador,
finalmente lo publicamos en noviembre de 2014 en el Cairo.
Ha llegado muy lejos. Publicamos 10.000 copias.
A la fecha, se ha descargado 3000 veces en formato PDF.
Escuché recientemente de un colega que lo iban a implementar en Somalía.
Van a producir una versión de esto en Somalía,
porque no hay ningún material allá.
Es muy bueno saberlo.
Y esta nueva Organización Árabe para el Manejo de los Cuerpos Electorales,
que esta tratando de profesionalizar
como se realizan elecciones en la región,
está usando también el material.
También la Liga Árabe ahora ha formado una unidad de observación panárabe,
y también lo utilizan.
Eso es excelente.
Sin embargo, esta guía es bastante complicada.
Es compleja y muchos de los términos son bastante técnicos,
la persona común no necesita conocer al menos un tercio de esta.
Las personas del Medio Oriente
han sido privadas de toda forma de educación cívica como la conocemos.
Es parte de nuestra formación en la escuela.
No existe realmente en esa parte del mundo,
y siento que es el derecho de todos
saber como funcionan estas cosas.
Es bueno ir pensando en producir un material de referencia
para la persona promedio,
y teniendo esto en mente,
tener una base para trabajar con ello,
y también tenemos tecnología,
por lo que podemos informar usando aplicaciones de celular,
videos, animaciones.
Hay muchas herramientas que pueden ser usadas
para comunicar estas ideas a las personas,
por primera vez en su propio idioma.
Nos enteramos sobre la miseria en medio oriente.
Escuchamos sobre el caos de la guerra y el terrorismo.
Sobre el sectarismo y todos los hechos negativos
que escuchamos todo el tiempo.
Lo que no escuchamos es sobre lo que piensa la gente común,
¿Cuáles son sus aspiraciones?
Proveamos los medios y las palabras.
La mayoría que no se expresa,
no lo hace por falta de palabras.
Esta mayoría necesita tener el conocimiento.
Es tiempo de proveer a la gente con las herramientas
para que puedan informarse.
La mayoría que no se expresa, no tiene que ser silenciosa.
Ayudemos a que tengan una voz.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)